le chantier nord stream de touche à sa
fin dans quelques jours le gaz le
gazoduc qui relie reliera pardon la
russie à l'allemagne on a retrouvé tout
de suite notre correspondante à moscou
vera goffman
bonjour verra le gazoduc sera donc
bientôt mise en service
bonjour sophy oui effectivement le
dernier tuyaux de nord stream 2 a été
soudé ce 6 septembre dans la mer
baltique ensuite elle ne restera plus
qu'à raccorder les deux parties du
gazoduc qui viennent de la côte
allemande et des eaux du danemark les
travaux sont quasiment terminées je vous
propose d'écouter
le 6 septembre les spécialistes du
navire poseur de canalisations fortuna
on soudait le dernier tuyaux de la
deuxième ligne du gazoduc nord stream 2
après quoi le tuyau portant le numéro
200 1858 sera immergé au fond de la mer
baltique dans les eaux allemandes la
prochaine étape sera la mise en oeuvre
de l'assemblage de la section du gazoduc
venant de la côte allemande avec celle
en provenance des eaux du danemark via
un raccordement au dessus de la surface
de l'eau ensuite des travaux de
préparation au lancement de la deuxième
ligne seront effectués afin de permettre
la mise en service du gazoduc avant la
fin de l'année en cours nord stream 2
contribuera à répondre aux besoins à
long terme du marché énergétique de
lieux en matière d'importation de gaz
naturel en fournissant des
approvisionnement fiable et sûr à des
conditions économiques raisonnables plus
tôt dans la journée c'est le ministre
russe des affaires étrangères sergueï
lavrov qui a déclaré que le gazoduc
commencerait fonctionner dans quelques
jours et ce malgré les pressions
exercées par washington écoutez
par exemple en ce qui concerne leur
stream de l'administration by donne n'a
pas changé de position ils sont toujours
opposés à ce projet mais ils comprennent
qu'il est impossible de l'arrêter si
vous comprenez que vous êtes obsédé par
une mission impossible à réaliser eh
bien le bon sens voudrait que vous
lavant donniez pour vous occuper de
quelque chose de réaliste voilà il est
donc nécessaire de parler et a cédé gare
le sommet était bien sûr je crois
positif
non stream ii et tu est un gazoduc d'une
longueur d'environ 1200 km qui passe par
le fond de la mer baltique et fournir à
l'europe en gaz naturel russe cette
nouvelle structure permettra d'augmenter
le volume de livraison de 55 milliards
de mètres cubes de gaz par an ce volume
sera suffisant pour approvisionner dans
six millions de foyers chaque année
c'est selon le président du groupe russe
gazprom alexeï miller le wrp recevra du
gaz russe par le biais du nouveau
gazoduc dès l'automne prochain merci
beaucoup pour tout ces précisions
verhaeghe hoffman depuis moscou